Joining us now some.
We're going to do the remarks
of the president's
claims and Daniel Dale
here to do that.
Daniel, thanks for joining us.
I appreciate it.
So President
Biden boasted about cutting the
last night.
Take a listen.
In the last two years,
my administration has cut the de
by more than $1.7 trillion.
The largest
deficit reduction in American hi
Daniel, is he right?
Don, this boast about cutting th
leaves out
such important context
that I'd say is misleading,
even though his numbers are righ
It is true
that the deficit declined
1.7 trillion in fiscal 21 22
compared to fiscal 2020.
But here's the key.
Experts have consistently told
CNN that Biden is taking
way too much credit for this dec
when he suggests
his own administration is respon
In reality, that decline
overwhelmingly occurred simply
because temporary pandemic
spending from 2020 expired as sc
And not only that, experts
tell me that Biden's own
actions, his legislation,
his orders
have on the whole significantly
increase deficits.
Dan White, a senior director of
research at Moody's Analytics,
which is a firm
Biden has repeatedly
cited, told me this On net,
the policies of the administrati
have increase the deficit,
not reduced it.
How much?
While the Committee
for a Responsible Federal Budget
and Advocacy group
estimates that Biden's actions
will add more than 4.8 trillion
to deficits from 2021 to 2031.
And that group's president,
Maya MacGuineas, told me
before the speech.
The White House deserves
credit for the 250 billion
of deficit reduction
they enacted through the Inflati
Reduction Act,
but should also take responsibil
for the 5 trillion
of deficit increasing policies
they signed into law or executiv
Now Biden can take some credit D
for the economic recovery,
which has boosted tax revenues.
That helps keep the deficit down
But overall,
what he's done
has made the deficit bigger,
not smaller Don.
So Daniel is he's
also claim that his predecessor
accumulated a lot of debt.
Listen to this.
Nearly
25% of the entire national debt
that took over 200 years to accu
was added
by just
one administration alone in the
Fair claim, Daniel.
It's more fair than the last one
Again, his numbers are correct,
but there's still some important
missing here.
In short,
Don Trump
wasn't solely responsible for th
increasing during his tenure.
Under Trump,
the debt did rise by a quarter.
It's now
about 31 trillion
and went up by about 8 trillion
under Trump.
Some of that was definitely Trum
undoing.
His unfunded
tax cuts were a major contributo
but a big chunk of the increase
was the trillions
in bipartisan COVID spending.
That's when the big Trump era
spike in the debt occurred.
In early to mid 2020.
Also, as always,
some of the increase
was because of spending
that is mandatory
because of decisions
from previous
presidents, from Medicare
and Medicaid
in the sixties
to President
George Bush's prescription
drug benefit to Obamacare.
So the debt blame game is common
to both parties.
It is tradition,
but the reality is more complica
than just like the debt belongs
to the president. Don.
All right.
Daniel Dale, thank you very much
Always keeping us up on all the
Let's bring in South Carolina Co
and Assistant Democratic leader
James Clyburn. For his reaction.
Good morning, sir.
It's so nice to have you in pers
Thank you very much for having m
All right.
Did we just see the beginning of
run for 2024 last night?
I think so and certainly hope so
Let's finish the job.
I thought that's a great refrain
And I do believe
he's led
the tremendous foundation for do
And I think the American people
is going to respond very positiv
I think I saw some of what you s
this morning that
from the beginning to the end
among independents as
his approval went way up.
70%.
This is
a positive reaction to the speec
How did you use so you graded.
Oh,
well I'll give him a little
more than 72%.
I thought it was the best effort
I've seen from him in a long, lo
You know,
I do a lot of speech making myse
not nearly on the level that he
But, you know,
when you're speaking to a group
and you get hecklers
the way you respond to that,
I think is demonstrative
of what kind of person you are.
And I saw in him last night
the kind of maturity
that the American people
would like to see in the preside
You took on the hecklers.
Let them have their say.
Give them a nice little smile
and responded in a very positive
You brought that up without us
even prompting you.
What that must been on,
that's on your mind was exactly
You know, because, you know,
I think unfairly so.
He gets a lot of flak from peopl
about not being able to do well.
And he gets off script.
He went off last night
did extremely well, came back on
and continue
to pursue his agenda,
which I think is a great agenda.
You think Kevin McCarthy
should say something to his
members about that?
I understand that he
did say
something to them about it befor
and they didn't listen.
When you're dealing with kinderg
it's kind of hard to get them to
to listen.
Just what is
how do you think that makes him
Because, look,
Caitlin pointed out earlier, I m
you and Nancy Pelosi,
who was you know, she was sort o
I should say
Speaker Pelosi, the former Speak
would calm some of the members d
but not it doesn't seem like
it was in this fashion.
Well, how do you think this make
know that she's never had their
down?
Nancy, we had discussions before
about how to
respond to certain things
and whether or not we should.
But I don't know
if it's worth their moments
during the State of the Union
where she would say
she would look and say, don't do
especially during President Trum
Probably so that's what I wrote.
Yeah, sure. Sure. But, you know,
we don't heckle.
I don't remember a Democrat ever
a president
in a State of the Union
or any other matter we may show
just association
with unappreciated this off
We may do it
with a smile or not smile,
facial expressions.
I sometimes do it as my head bow
my head to to pray.
And I sometimes
shake my head to say I don't agr
but to heckle.
I mean, that's not the way adult
You let the president have his s
You show your disapproval,
but you don't heckle.
You may not stand up but yelling
calling the president a lie, esp
when it's not a lie.
It is absolute and the truth.
I've seen the document
put out by Rick Scott.
He didn't call his name,
but I know his name.
The former governor of Florida,
he was running the Senate
reelect stuff and he put out a d
calling for sunsetting Social Se
and Medicare.
And then Senator Johnson from up
in Wisconsin
said we ought to do it every yea
rather than every five years
that the document calls it.
Now, he said some Republicans
want to cut Medicare.
Those are two that want to cut M
And that, to me,
made this speech all the worthwh
I think they're taking offense w
folks here
if tying it to the debt
ceiling is what they're saying.
I think they're taking offense w
that to the debt ceiling because
it should not be tied
to the debt ceiling.
We didn't talk to the debt ceili
What they're trying to do is mak
for the cuts that's been done be
We understand the way this game
at stake is that Gingrich was sa
you know, I don't want to get ri
I want to reduce it to the level
of being able to drive it in the
He was talking about Medicare
when he said that
I think we're out of time.
So
you you can ask, didn't you have
you wanted to ask him to work?
But we appreciate you
and we hope you come back.
Well, it's nice to have you.
It's just below us.
Looking debonair, this morning,
thank you very much.
Said he was trying to keep up
with everyone. Tries to keep up
Absolutely. Follow in his footst
Thank you.
It's always a pleasure to see yo
Thank you so much.